I think that personal responsibility is
always the key you can't always expect
you know government to do something for
you other corporations to do something
for you we are consumer based society so
everything that's on the marketplace is
because we said we wanted it or because
someone convinced us that we wanted it
and it looked shiny and we got it so we
have to be conscientious consumers and
we have to say this is what I want to
buy this is what I want to entertain
myself this is where I wish to go those
kinds of things and then that guides the
marketplace we cannot just wait for
government although as taking seizing
personal responsibility I think we have
to go to our representative part of
taking personal responsibility I think
is that you've got to make your
legislators listen to you and it's not
as hard as people think for example the
farm bill subsidizes mega corporations
like Tyson's and conagra these aren't
you know Willie Nelson's poor farmers
these are mega businesses they give lot
of money to the election campaigns and
in return our government shells out
billions of taxpayer dollars to them in
subsidies and what do they do they then
buy up all this pork and milk and these
other unhealthy fattening foods and dump
them in the school system so that our
children are eating them you know you're
a constituent you should get on the
phone to the your member your Senators
your members of Congress and say I don't
want to subsidize these big corporations
that are killing America with health
care costs with obesity that are being
cruel to animals so I think that
personal responsibility can have a voice
on Capitol Hill but only if we the
consumers and the people who have
elected those officials make sure
they're hearing us more than their
hearing